ces caméras sympas à chaque fois
pensez-vous que je pourrais aimer le désordre Roylott alors qu'est
-ce que cela signifie de partir de vous connaissez la
caméra oh merde non vous voulez que je n'y
entre pas allez-y
levez-vous le cul en utilisant super pour aller que
mesdames  bizarre aussi
elle vit juste en dessous de moi avez-vous vu en
bas Google truc nous allons juste l'attacher
c'est ce qui descend le lien car il est
comme quelle est cette caméra
cette vieille sur la dame qui a été tuée elle
vit juste en dessous de moi
allons vérifier en bas il y a  du sang
partout
Katie et Kristi qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
truc de magie noire oh ouais mec j'ai fait des
rêves les plus fous
oh ça ressemble à une morsure ou quelque chose
ouais mais avoir ce sentiment bizarre avez-
vous déjà eu l'impression que quelque chose
vous regarde
vous avez changé vous avez le  caméra alors
quoi de neuf mec hé comment as-tu fait ça je
ne sais pas ce qui m'arrive
c'est Katie c'est Christie ma
belle-mère alors le COS demande à Christie
puis Katie ceux qui sont marqués ils
deviennent les hôtes permanents alors quoi de
va arriver